merci la parole est à madame nicole
ameline
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires européennes
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
interroger sur la libye et sur la
stratégie globale de l'union européenne
au sud
chacun sait qu'aujourd'hui une seule une
solution politique est apte à résoudre
la crise libyenne qui impacte toute la
région méditerranéenne mais aussi notre
propre continent
je veux vous interroger sur l'action et
la responsabilité de l'europe dans le
règlement politique de cette crise et
sur sa capacité à reconstruire un pays
stratégique et au delà à stabiliser un
espace qui l'est tout autant
vous le savez aujourd'hui un accord est
possible en libye il est proche mais
dans le même temps il répond certes à la
mobilisation positive des pays riverains
mais aussi à l'action internationale la
mise en place d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale serait en effet le mieux à
même de répondre à toutes les questions
qui se posent sécuritaires politiques y
compris migratoires car nous savons que
la question des migrations se réglera à
terre dans la restauration des contrôles
aux frontières dans la stabilisation
globale de la région mais aussi dans une
approche du développement de la région
subsaharienne plus adapté aux réalités
actuelles
c'est dire la priorité qui s'attache à
ce que l'union européenne mobilise ses
efforts son énergie pour obtenir cet
accord politique mais plus encore
je souhaiterais que nous puissions
connaître l'action de la france ces
initiatives pour mobiliser au delà de
cet accord la communauté européenne dans
la reconstruction politique et
économique de cette région
cela suppose une volonté une stratégie
nouvelle un redéploiement de la
politique de voisinage et surtout la
mise en place de solidarités nouvelles
dans le cadre d'un partenariat
stratégique avec le sud qui n'est
totalement pas suffisant aujourd'hui
alors ma question monsieur le ministre
c'est quelles initiatives comprendre la
france dans ce sens merci merci la
parole est à monsieur harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée nicole ameline je vous remercie
de votre question sur la situation en
libye qui est un pays qui traverse à la
fois une crise politique comme vous
l'avez dit mais une crise aussi
sécuritaire depuis plusieurs mois
poursuit ce qu'il ya dans ce pays deux
parlements de gouvernement plusieurs
groupes armées qui s'affrontent et que
cela comporte des risques pour la
stabilité des pays voisins mais aussi
des risques humanitaire très important
pour la population libyenne aussi pour
les populations africaines victimes de
toutes sortes de trafics y compris le
trafic d'êtres humains
la situation politique sur le terrain
elle est bloquée la reprise du dialogue
politique est suspendu aux réponses des
différentes parties libyennes au projet
d'accord que le représentant spécial du
secrétaire général des nations unies
monsieur bernardino leon à préparer le
congrès général national de tripoli d'un
côté qui est l'ancien parlement a
accepté ce projet d'accord le 17 juin
mais veut y apporter les amendements et
le camp de tobrouk c'est à dire la
chambre des représentants qui est là
l'autorité actuellement reconnues ne
s'est pas encore prononcée
définitivement et souhaitent elles mêmes
des modifications donc l'action de la
france c'est de tout faire pour inciter
ces deux parties en particulier le camp
de tobrouk à accepter ce quatrième
projet d'accord c'est celui qui doit
permettre de pacifier le pays de
reconstruire un état qui soit capable de
lutter efficacement contre le terrorisme
parce que c'est le deuxième point cette
situation de crise politique a créé une
situation sécuritaire très dégradée vous
le savez la libye est aujourd'hui le
carrefour de nombreuses menaces pour la
région et pour l'europe
les groupes jihadistes dont dash
profitent du vide ita étatiques et du
climat de guerre civile pour s'y
implanter et l'absence d'état fait le
lit à tous les trafics trafic d'armes
trafic d'êtres humains
je l'évoquais donc l'europe doit se
mobiliser
elle doit d'abord mettre en oeuvre
l'opération eunavfor med de surveillance
des côtes et de lutte contre les
trafiquants mais aussi vous l'avez dit
donnez la priorité dans le cadre de la
politique européenne de voisinage au
soutien à la stabilité mes